was ist genau passiert und was können
sie uns sagen ja ich kann ihnen schon
sagen dass es gegen 6 uhr 30 aller
alarmierung haben
ein geiselnehmer hatte in der
justizvollzugsanstalt eben eine geisel
genommen
es kam mir zum großeinsatz der polizei
wir haben den raum hier abgesperrten
natürlich auch einsatzkräfte in das
gebäude gebracht nach circa drei stunden
konnten wir die geisel unverletzt
befreien
bei dem polizeieinsatz ist der
geiselnehmer aber ums leben gekommen
die umstände dieser dieser geiselnahme
kann man da schon irgendwie was sagen
wie sich das abgespielt haben sollen
wissen sie da schon was
das wäre jetzt zu früh schon mit details
an die öffentlichkeit zu gehen wir
müssen natürlich den genauen tathergang
rekonstruieren
die ermittlungen laufen natürlich dazu
auf hochtouren und auch der
polizeieinsatz muss natürlich genau
rekonstruiert und nachbereitet werden
das sind alles unsere aufgaben die wir
derzeit mit akribie angehen
nehmen sie uns mit wenn so ein notruf
kommt also ob das jetzt die jva ist oder
geiselnahme was was spielt sich dann
polizeilich ab welche welche maßnahmen
werden getroffen
damit wir uns noch so ein bisschen
vorstellen wie eine geiselnahme haben
wir glücklicherweise alle noch nicht
wahrscheinlich am eigenen leib erlebt
die polizei ist natürlich sehr einsatz
erfahren gerade hier polizeipräsidium
münster auch mit solchen großlagen da
gibt es natürlich vorbereitete
entscheidungen und fähige so dass sie
dort sehr schnell einsatzfähig sind
sodass wir spezialisten zum eindruck
bekommen wir wissen auch genau welche
entscheidungen zu treffen haben
da sind wir sehr gut vorbereitet jetzt
ist jemand ums leben gekommen mutmaßlich
der geiselnehmer
wie wird die polizei jetzt weiter mit
eines sehr wahrscheinlich durch einen
polizisten ums leben gekommen wie sind
dann die mechanismen wie wird diese tat
dann dieses geschehen weiter ermittelt
das ist ganz normaler standard wenn eine
person durch einen polizeieinsatz im
leben ums leben kommt wird natürlich
genau der tathergang rekonstruiert
es wird ermittelt ob alles mit rechten
dingen zugegangen ist ob es eben ein
gerechtfertigter unmittelbarer zwang war
ob die alltagssituationen dass in dem
fall hergegeben hat das sind alles
ermittlungen die natürlich standardmäßig
laufender wie auch die
staatsanwaltschaft eingeschaltet
nach unseren ermittlungen
nach unseren recherchen stand soll es so
gewesen sein dass der mann einen
hubschrauber gefordert haben soll um
dann jva zu verlassen klingt ein
bisschen nach science fiction und nach
hollywood
gibt es denn da eventuell kann er uns
auch das wäre zu früh jetzt genau den
hergang der geiselnahme und seine
forderung darzustellen das ist auch
ebenfalls auch noch gegenstand der
ermittlungen
das wäre mir jetzt zu früh dazu erste
spekulationen zu bestätigen oder gar zu
veröffentlichen wir sind bild und wie
ihr liefert dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren